prayers in Whitechapel mosque in East
London were all the more reflective
horrors of Christchurch may have
happened on the other side of the world
but they feel close to home the added
security around mosques in the UK isn't
just for show there's no intelligence to
suggest a copycat attack here but
British Muslims feel more threatened
than ever by far-right extremism in this
country we may be more than eleven
thousand miles away from Christchurch in
New Zealand we fill the ripples of
hatred we fill the ripples of fear and
we fill the ripples of sorrow our
brothers and sisters in Christchurch
last year religious hate crime rose by
40 percent in England and Wales there
were 94 thousand religiously motivated
offenses more than half of those
targeted were Muslim so why is it on the
rise one of the most shocking attacks by
a member of the far-right was in 2016
the murder of MP Joe Cox her husband
says Islamophobic rhetoric has become
too mainstream
I think Islamophobia has become the new
acceptable form of racism if you look
again at the figures there are more
people who have very limited experience
of Muslims but have high concern about
it and in some cases that concern is
moving over into Islamophobia in 2017
Darren Osborne drove her van into
pedestrians outside Finsbury Park mosque
killing one person and injuring nine
others Osbourne and what he did here in
Finsbury Park is listed as an
inspiration by the attacker in New
Zealand in his so-called manifesto but
the far-right is also inspired by
Islamic extremism in many ways they
mirror each other both exploit
grievances and encourage intolerance and
generate distrust in anyone who doesn't
subscribe to their point of view
rallies such as this one in Sunderland
attended by you Kip leader Jared batten
focus on issues such as rape and child
exploitation by Asian men and grooming
gangs so the age of consent in Islamic
culture is a lot more elastic than it
would be in the football lads Alliance
see this is legitimate protest others as
whipping up hatred against an entire
religious group whatever the cause of
increased hate crimes it requires
practical solutions the man who wrote
the UK strategy for religious spaces
says mosques should consider more
permanent security plans if you go to a
synagogue they've taken security
seriously they have fences around you
you can only get in through layers of
security as you would expect most secure
buildings and of course mosques
don't do that their weather but it's
very difficult because they are designed
to be open door in Hyde Park New
Zealanders held a vigil like any attack
on cultural cohesion it has brought
communities closer together in
compassion for the victims and support
for those who feel threatened Jason
Ferrell Sky News